so we figured out that you can get the
book stack the overhang of the books to
be half the harmonic sum with n books
you can get out HN over to where HN is
this harmonic sum or harmonic number the
question is how we gonna estimate or
calculate what this sum is now it turns
out there is no simple formula for
exactly what this sum is but there is a
simple formula that estimates it quite
accurately and we get the estimation by
bounding the sum by integrals and so
let's look at this integral method for
estimating sums remember what I wanted
was the sum of 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 down
to 1 over N so let's form some unit
width rectangles of heights equal to the
amount that I want so here's a rectangle
of height one rectangle of height 1/2
rectangle of height a third I'm going
out here if you can actually count to
eight but let's propose that this is a
height 1 over N and what I know is that
the total area of these rectangles is
actually equal to the number that I want
the total area of these rectangles is
the harmonic number and I'm interested
in a lower bound for H n because I want
to know how far I can get out I want to
tight lower bound and says H n is larger
than a certain amount that's the amount
that I'm sure that I can stack out and
books so the way I'm going to get a
lower bound on this number H n is by
looking at this curve that goes through
the corners of the rectangles and if you
check it that curve is 1 over X plus 1
that is the point here is when X when x
is 0 I'm at 1 over 1 when I when X is 1
I met 1/2 the height of the second
rectangle and so on so 1 over X plus 1
is a curve that is strictly below the
boundaries of all these rectangles that
means that the area under 1 over X plus
1 going from 0 to n is a lower bound on
HN because it's a lower bound on the
area of the rectangles so
hñ equals the area of the rectangles
it's greater than the area over 1 over X
plus 1 which of course is equal to the
integral from 0 to n of 1 over X plus
one on which shifting variables is the
same as the integral from 1 to n plus 1
of 1 over X DX which of course we know
is the natural logarithm of n plus 1 so
there we have it
the overhang that you need for 3 bucks
which is BN greater than or equal to 3
means that H n has to be greater equal
to 6 so by this estimate I need log of n
plus 1 greater than or equal to 6
in order to get 3 books out I that the
back end of the top book is 2 books past
the edge of the table and the and the
right-hand end of the top for the snap
book is 3 book lengths past the edge of
the table
so my bound tells me that I need n books
such that log of n plus 1 is greater
equal to 6 well exponentiating both
sides the right hand side becomes e to
the 6th and I figure out that as long as
n is greater than or equal to e to the 6
minus 1 books rounded up of course
because there's only they can't have
fractions of a book you get an estimate
that with 403 books I can actually get
my stack to stick out three book lengths
past the edge of the table if you do the
actual calculation instead of the
estimate it turns out that 227 books are
enough but so this estimates a little
off but for our purposes it tells us a
dramatic fact which is that we know that
log of n plus 1 approaches infinity as n
approaches infinity and that means that
with enough books I can get out as far
as I want you tell me how many book
lengths you want to be out I'll use the
log n formula to calculate how many
books I need to get that far out so
here's an example of some students in
the class some years ago decided to do
this as an experiment now when we used
to do this in class we first tried to do
it with a big heavy textbook that we
used and we kept trying to get them to
balance and go out over the edge of the
table and they failed because it turns
out that textbooks are heavy and they
compress they're not the rigid
rectangular cross-sections that our
model was based on but CD cases work
very well they are more rigid than don't
compress easily and they're very
lightweight so that they don't cause
problems with distortions because of the
size of the stack and so you can
actually get CD cases to stick out
pretty far this is an example where it's
43 CD cases hi and the top four cases
are completely past the edge of the
table the leftmost edge is about one
point eight oh one point nine case case
lengths past the table there's another
view of it from the guy who made the
stack and of course they were right on
the edge of stability in trying to get
the the CDs to stick out as far as
possible so if you notice these little
spaces there in terms of the balancing
it's really just on the brink of falling
over if you sneeze add a little tip but
if you don't sneeze at it it's stable
and you get the top CD out that far so
while we're at it let's get an upper
bound for agent we just got a lower
bound of HN but the same kind of logic
of using an integral will give you an
upper bound for HN what I do now is I
run a curve from the upper right corners
of the rectangles and that curve is
simply 1 over X so an upper bound for
the harmonic number H n is the area
under 1 over X out to n Plus this one
and so I get an upper bound that says
that the harmonic number HN is less than
the integral from 1 to N of 1 over X DX
plus 1 or it's equal to 1 plus log of n
so combining those two bounds that I got
by looking at a curve that's a lower
bound on the area and a curve that's an
upper bound on the area and integrating
I discover that HN is bracketed between
the natural log of n plus 1 and 1 plus
the Latin natural log of n now these two
numbers o log of n plus 1 and 1 plus log
of n are very close and they get closer
and closer as n grows so it turns out to
what we can say pretty accurately is
that HN is
is asymptotically equal to log n it's
approximately equal to log n and the
precise definition of this tilde symbol
that I've highlighted in magenta is
called asymptotically equal and the
general definition of asymptotically
equal that HN is asymptotically equal to
log n is that a function f of n is
asymptotically equal to a function G of
n when the limit of their quotient goes
to 1 that is to say as a multiplicative
factor each is within a constant one of
the other in the limit 1 plus epsilon of
1 plus or minus epsilon of GN is going
to bracket FN and vice versa
asymptotic equivalents are asymptotic
equality let's do an example so the
remark would be for example that n
square plus n is asymptotically equal to
N squared why well let's look at the
limit as n approaches infinity of N
squared plus n over N squared it's the
same as simplifying algebraically the
limit of 1 over 1 plus n as n approaches
infinity that term goes to 0
sure enough the limit is 1 and so these
two terms are asymptotically equal the
idea of asymptotically equal is that all
we care about is the high order term the
low order terms will disappear and we're
looking at the principal term that
controls the growth rate of the
functions when we look at them up to
asymptotic equivalence so let's step
back for just a moment and generalize
what we've done here with estimating the
harmonic sum there's a general method
called the integral method where in this
particular case suppose we have a
function f of the positive real valued
function that's weakly decreasing like 1
over X then let's let s be the sum from
I equals 1 to N of F of I so I was
interested where f of X f of X was 1
over X and I wanted the sum from 1 over
1 to n of 1 over I which was the end
harmonic number and I was comparing that
to the integral from 1 to N of f of X
or 1 over X in our example so if I is
the integral and s is the sum that I
want what we can conclude really is that
in general the sum is bracketed between
the integral plus the first term of FF
of 1 in the sum and the integral plus
the last term of the sum remember F is
weakly decreasing so f of n is smaller
than F of 1 there's a similar theorem
actually just reverse F of 1 and F of N
to use an integral estimate to get a
bound on a weakly increasing function
and that gives us a general tool for
estimating of the growth rate of songs